from one of the first studies of voting
the democratic citizen is expected to be
well informed about political affairs to
know what the issues are what
alternatives are proposed what the
likely consequences are and beginning
with that study voting the systematic
study of public opinion thereafter as
consistently focused on debunking the
myth of the responsible citizen study
after study has disclosed that citizens
pay only erratic and minimal attention
to politics and not surprisingly they
know scarcely anything about it and they
fall short of what it is that
responsible says and should be now I
have to be said that it's a mystery it's
certainly a mystery to me who expected
the Democratic citizen to be so
well-informed any of many sharp-eyed
observers have seen that it's just not
so a favorite quote comes from Bryce on
19th century how little solidity and
substance there is in the political and
social beliefs of 19 persons out of 20
these beliefs when examined most resolve
themselves into two or three prejudices
and aversions two or three pre
possessions for a particular party or
section of a party to a three phrase or
catchwords suggesting or embodying
arguments which the man who repeats them
has not analyzed now Bryce's tone is
harsher
and it's more moralistic than that of
contemporary researchers but it does
capture the thrust the main thrust of of
their claims succinctly that ordinary
citizens are empty-headed and that's the
classical problem of non attitudes and
that their muddle-headed and that is the
famous problem of minimal constraint
connections among ideal loans and just
so far as both of those claims hold the
political preferences of ordinary
citizens are embarrassingly elastic one
moment they'll line up on one side of an
issue the next they'll line up on the
opposite side and what I want to do
today is to consider how far those
claims are valid and I'm going to start
with the most dramatic illustration of
them and that's research on issue
framing and preference reversals and
what I mean to show is that that those
findings are valid but they don't mean
what they've been taken to me but first
i want to make explicit you know what
what the claims are of the mainstream
view of public opinion and these quotes
are taken from the second most often
cited work on public opinion John
zollars origin and nature of public
opinion which is adjusted an exceptional
work I mean it's just own it's a
marvelously systematic and compelling
account working out a principal idea
and any and and here is a at the heart
of it most people on most issues don't
really think any particular thing most
people really aren't sure what their
opinions are on most political matters
most of the people most of the time just
make it up as they go along that's
actually the title of a whole chapter
making it up to go along now those are
just extraordinary claims and on their
face they're not obviously right so the
question is what what does zoller mean
by them and on his representation
citizens we receive information about
political choices and some of the
information is favorable to supporting a
policy and some is unfavorable and when
we're asked to make a choice some
considerations but not others come to
mind and the question is which ones and
much depends the argument runs on what's
immediately accessible in our minds
what's salient at the moment that we
make our choices and and that depends on
the immediate circumstances at the
moment of choice so at one point in time
there may be more favorable
considerations than unfavorable ones
that come to mind and we say yes to the
policy but at another point in time
there are other considerations that are
made salient more or less by chance by
the circumstances of the moment and we
decide no we reverse our position and
there is no more diagnostic symptom of
irrationality than preference reversal
it's not merely that it is the criteria
sign of irrationality but preference
reversal is the signal citizens are open
to elite manipulation and and the door
opens because whoever gets the frame an
issue whoever gets to put an issue in
terms that makes alien one set of
considerations but not another gets to
decide what the outcome is going to be
and so elite aim to frame issues in
order that they can merely by the
presentation of the terms of the issue
win the support of of a majority and and
insofar as that view of framing and
preference reversals is right then
citizens really are they're not just
puppet whose strings are being pulled by
elite their puppets in in yet another
sense it's it's a matter of their
reactions being a stimulus and a
response there's um it just doesn't make
a lot of sense to speak about their
reasoning about an issue they're
deliberating about it not even they're
being deliberate about a political
choice now as it happens there just
isn't a lot of evidence for a key
postulate of solace model namely that
most people have about a roughly equal
balance positive than negative
considerations that they can call on but
there is a great deal of evidence
for the power of framing issue framing
to induce preference reversals and it's
and it's not possible and it just isn't
acceptable to dismiss that evidence and
if you want to give an account that
posits that there is coherence of choice
by citizens it is necessary to account
for those framing effects and preference
reversals and the key I think the key
I'm going to rely on is that defining
attribute of democratic politics is
competition that was the lesson of
Schumpeter democratic politics consists
in an organized competition between
elites for public power and as part of
that competition elites compete against
one another in the framing of issues
each side does what's in its power to
make salient consider that
considerations that are favorable to
their side and it's the collision of
views that so far from producing
confusion is a condition for clarity and
coherence here's a classic example of a
framing experiment the issue is whether
or not the Ku Klux Klan should be
allowed to hold a rally and it's a
randomized experiment and one half of
the respondents are assigned to a
condition where they're asked whether or
not the Klan should be able to have a
rally and in the course
to being asked about about that they're
reminded of the value of free speech in
the other condition everything is
exactly the same but except for their
attention being directed to the value of
free speech they're told well there is a
risk of violence and lo and behold it's
observed that in the free speech frame a
majority supports the right of the clan
to hold the rally and in the risk of
violence frame a majority opposes it
which is actually one one thinks about
it a curious way to think about politics
so we undertook to see if we could
examine the role of conflict conflicting
ideas when it comes to making judgments
about civil liberties and civil rights
and and there's just a big emphasis that
it's just not acceptable to take a look
at previous work and say well they just
got it all wrong and now I'm going to
tell you what the whole truth and the
real truth of the matter is because if
the work was done by good people they
probably didn't get it all wrong so we
began and with the replication and this
is a general population sample as it
happens from the United States at the
issue again is the right of the KKK to
hold a rally the frame that's the mean
level of support for civil liberties
when respondents attention
is directed to free speech when however
they fall in the next treatment
condition its risk of violence the
majority flips around and opposes but
then the question is what happens when
those two considerations are both
brought to people's attention now it's
5050 so you look 50 50 and you say hey
that's like random they're flipping
coins what is it that we should mean
when we say of someone that they've made
a coherent choice a proposal coherent
choice is any choice where you choose
from among the alternatives on offer the
one most consonant with your general
view of the matter general view of the
matter what's the general view of the
matter that's relevant to issues of
civil liberties you can think of there
is a clash of values order is a value
individual freedom is a value and so
what we created was an index that rank
ordered people from those who attach
most importance to order over individual
freedom to those who attach most
importance to the value of individual
freedom over order and in results i'm
going to show you are the treatment
condition where respondents get both
ostensibly conflicting considerations
along the horizontal axis you've got
people ordered from
rank ordered from those for whom order
is their dominating value to those for
whom its freedom the vertical axis is
support for civil liberties and that is
just about a steeple on as one can hope
to observe and an empirical study and
what it says is that people are choosing
the alternative yes the KKK rallies no
to KKK rallies conditional on almost
wholly conditional on their general view
of the relative importance of the values
of order and freedom what appeared to be
just random behavior 5050 actually is
the product of choices that are well and
deeply grounded and it's the collision
of these opposing considerations
violence importance of free speech that
allows people to sort out which
alternative of those on offer best fits
their general view of the matter now
those results I think open the door to a
kind of broader view of
I'm supposed to say I've brought a view
of information processing okay so I'd
say information processing but what I
really talking about is reasons that is
what I think people are responsive to
these reasons and as it happens it's
it's a colleague of of yours John
Bullock who really has done a pivotal
study that shows the necessity for
reconsideration of the relative roles of
kind of automatic reflexive responses to
partisan cues and consideration of
policy relevant information this the
standard finding is that in experiments
where people in the treatment condition
the policy alternatives are labeled
they're given party labels there's also
some information that's given about the
policy but the partisan branding Trump's
any effect the exposure to policy
information may have and it's mine is
one of those neat moves that is just
totally obvious xpost but just nobody
conceived at ex ante what Bullock
noticed was that the exposure to policy
information in fact consisted of being
exposed to very brief very vague usually
one sentence or two sentences and so
what he did in a series of experiments
was he presented respondents with
newspaper article lengths discussions of
policy and he also assigned them to
where the all policy alternatives were
party branded and they weren't party
branded and what he found was that yes
party cues mattered but policy
considerations if they're presented in
substantive detail mountain matter more
now I want to follow up bollocks lead
and consider a specific form in which
information matters and that is as I've
said reasons question what does it take
to show that voters are responsive to
reasons Wow here are the results of an
ingenious experiment by Laura Stoecker
the focus of the experiment is on
affirmative action affirmative action
comes in a lot of different flavors and
degrees stoker it shows a really hard
form of it mandatory job quotas and
national sample these are for whites
only in the control condition
respondents are asked whether or not
large companies should have mandatory
job quotas for the hiring of blacks then
in a treatment condition they're asked
exactly same question but they're given
a reason for those quotas namely that in
these large companies blacks are
underrepresented in the labor force and
in the third condition they're asked
exactly the same question they're given
a reason but it's a different reason now
it's these companies
have discriminated against blacks
affirmative action is not a popular
policy so you get only a little bit more
than one out of five who are willing to
say yes I I support it what happens when
they're given a reason nothing nothing
indistinguishable level of support what
happens if they're given a different
reason okay there's still less than the
majority that supports affirmative
action all those it happens that really
is a substantial level of responsiveness
so what's important about that
experiment why do I think why do I say
that it's ingenious because what the
design allowed Stoker to show was that
it's the particular reason that matters
the particular argument that's being
made not being argued whiffed it's not
pliability its persuasion ok here's
another experiment that makes the same
point but maybe just a little bit more
sharply it was inspired by a classic
experiment gosh you might actually have
been done at Yale the Xerox experiments
so here's how the experiment works for
everybody who knows when Xerox machines
were we're primary instrument
in an office so there's a Xerox machine
it's busy there's the experimenter has a
secret Confederate the Confederate goes
up to the line jumps the cue goes to the
head of the line and and says excuse me
I've got to make a copy that's right
sweetie it it's just ingenious I mean it
has the grammatical form of a reason but
it's not a reason everybody is in line
for exactly that same purpose and so the
idea is to see you know sort of who's
going to yield so it's a that suggested
and and this is comes from a study in
France that my colleague Simon
Jacqueline and I were part of that
experiment suggested that it really is
worthwhile to try and distinguish
between reasons and pseudo reasons
between arguments that are content free
and arguments that are content Laden
is it the case that citizens are capable
of distinguishing between reasons and
pseudo reasons so interviews go on at a
very rapid rate I mean it is an
astonishment to me that so many people
have written about the erratic behavior
of people and public opinion interviews
without having any sense at all of how
quick things go I asked you a question
you give an answer I ask you another one
you give me an answer whatever answer
you gave me I ask you another question
and another and another so that
answering choosing sides is a
probabilistic process it's not a
deterministic side sometimes the initial
response is on the mark and it reflects
your general view of the matter and
sometimes it doesn't so what we designed
with is it is a variation on what's
called the counter-argument technique in
this case the issue is the standard
social welfare issue about whether the
government should do more or not for the
unemployed and then randomly if you took
the position that's liberal in the
American sense you were one half of the
folks were signed the content latent
counter-argument you know if the
unemployment benefits are too high then
unemployed will not be encouraged to
look for a job but one half got a
counter argument that was free of
content just you know if you think about
all the problems of life and you know
that this will you change then the
question is will you change your mind
will you go to the other side of the
issue and on the other hand for those
who took a conservative position
randomly one half of the time
they got a content Laden
counter-argument today's benefits there
are many families that just can't get by
or they got exactly the same content
free counter-argument
first question can people tell a
difference between reasons and pseudo
reasons so another way of putting that
is we know that citizens vary in their
level of political sophistication some
are comparatively well informed engaged
some pay scarcely any attention the
politics to what extent we asked was it
the case that it required some degree of
political awareness and sophistication
to know whether or not you'd been given
a reason to change your position or a
pseudo reason so horizontal axis is the
degree of political sophistication and
vertical axis is the probability of
change in response to a content free
counter argument and that is a flat line
which is I want to say which is actually
worth remembering and and taking as
something that you might want to reflect
on because what it's saying is that even
those who have a minimal degree of
awareness of politics were minimally
engaged are just as good as those who
are sophisticated in recognizing when
they haven't been given a relevant
reason to change their position ok so
now what about content Laden
counter-arguments who's most likely to
be responsive to them well in a general
way the answers got to be clear the less
sophisticated you are the less
informational mass you have the less
informational national
have the more likely you are to yield
when given some information to induce
you to take another position but
actually the question is just a little
bit more interesting than that I said
that the process of making political
choices is probabilistic and that means
on any given occasion some people choose
a position that's consonant with their
general view of the matter some don't
suppose that it happens you look at
those who chose a position on this issue
and it is an issue at the center of
French politics and it's consistent with
their general view of the matter then
just as the best of previous research
would suggest those who are less
anchored by sophistication and
information are most responsive to
exposure to new information but what if
the initial position that you took
wasn't really the one which on
reflection on deliberation is the one
that would best represent your overall
orientation then as you can see on the
one side those who have less
sophistication again because they have
less informational mass are more likely
to be responsive to the content
counter-argument but it is the most
sophisticated who are just as responsive
just as likely to change the
relationship is curvilinear it's not
linear
so so what about up to this point what
I've argued what I hope I've persuaded
you to consider is that contrary to the
canonical view preference for reversals
are just not a built-in feature of
public opinion the voters are responsive
to information that's right but its
information primarily in the form of
relevant reasons relevant that is in
light of their general view of the
matter and I now I want to consider this
be the last of the empirical
demonstrations a really much harder
problem and that's support for civil
liberties there is there have been
studies of exceptional integrity and
imagination I'm thinking above all of
Samuel Stauffers study of communism
conformity and civil liberties which was
done at the height of McCarthy's joseph
mccarthy's power and and staffer
demonstrated that the general public
though supportive of democratic
principles in the abstract were
frighteningly unwilling to support them
in controversial cases like the rights
of suspected calmness
by contrast community leaders political
activists those who were social notables
and the jargon elites social and
political elites they were far more
likely to stand by civil liberties and
civil rights than ordinary citizens and
and and this is a finding that was
replicated by among others my teacher
herlofsky and it has led to the idea
that it is elites that are the
custodians and guardians of democratic
values because study ins and guardians
is a quote from a classic article by
Herbert makovsky on the problem
I actually don't think that's
I I don't think that it's right the
inferences that were drawn from those
from from from the latter study
particularly and the ones that followed
but I do think that but I know that the
impact that they've had is to undermine
confidence in anyone who's knowledgeable
about the competence of ordinary
citizens to think about political
matters it's the undermined their their
confidence that citizens can really hold
it together when it comes to a crisis
over civil liberties and that is the
reason for my interest in the Danish
cartoon crisis now I wish that it had
gotten some other name you know cartoon
in crisis like this I just tend to
undermine each other but it but it was
it was the biggest crisis and Danish
politics said the prime minister since
the Second World War so the newspaper
and Aarhus in September of 2005
publishes the 12 of these cartoons how
many of you have actually seen the
cartoons you know it's interesting
because most of them are actually making
fun of other Danish cartoonist set and
writers for making a big deal about this
and I'm told but if you have a Danish
sense of humor some of the some of the
captions are really quite funny but but
even when they've been translated for me
I don't get it but but there are there
there certainly are several that are are
blatantly offensive the this as as
political scientists should instantly
appreciate is a wonderful opportunity
for elite and so Middle East governments
led by Egypt decide that they've got to
defend the faith and they send some
ambassadors everybody's a politician
okay and politicians have incentives to
do things that they think are going to
help them next time around they run and
so the Danish Prime Minister decides
that not he's not going to take a
courtesy meeting you go say absolutely
not freedom of speech is not is not
something you can compromise which is an
interesting line of reasoning but quite
easily say that after the meeting anyway
and then then things start to take off
there's a bounty then there comes
delegation of your mom's from Aarhus and
then everybody gets into starts to get
into the act saying this is outside
Denmark this is really something
terrible January the 7th the cartoons
are reprinted three weeks things explode
there's boycotts ambassadors or recalled
the Danish flag is burnt the embassies
to embassies are burnt to the ground
huge demonstrations and and
assassination attempts one after another
after another after another but all
happily unsuccessful
to kill the cartoonists especially the
one that did the cartoon with the bomb
in the turban and one really quite
elaborate 12 machine gun everybody in
the newspaper offices at the newspaper
in Aarhus things are as tense and as as
uncertain and as chaotic and there is as
much fear as their conceivably can be
there are colleagues at the university
of aarhus led by an exceptional an
exceptional woman Lisa togepi and 33 of
her younger colleagues ruins to bloggers
at Michael Bank Patterson and ruined
slow cows and I they're applying for
money but even when I have no money at
all they're getting instruments ready
and so as it happens they get the money
and there in the field by January the
fifth and they do the first of three
surveys it's just a remarkable act of
imaginative design that they undertook
in a period of just a couple of months
and executed a study that is as well
conducted as as any I know over here and
and and they na na and they did a number
of experiments and I want to show you
the results of one and and I think that
it is a trophy example of how simple can
be splendid
the principal concern that they had was
how big the backlash was going to be
against Muslim immigrants so what they
did was in the course of the interview
they randomly assigned one end to the
respondents to being asked for standard
questions about civil liberties and
civil rights about Muslim immigrants and
they randomly assigned one end to being
asked exactly the same questions except
about Islamic fundamentalist and since
the assignments are random it means that
those who are being asked about Muslim
immigrants and those who are being asked
about Islamic fundamentalists are in
every respect alike unobservable as well
as durable chance differences aside
can't get analysis it's simpler than
that here's a crosstab there are four
questions right to take part in the
public debate to demonstrate speak at
high schools there's actually a reason
for in the Danish context for asking
that opposition to telephone tapping I
was asked to come over to evaluate the
results of the study and and I asked to
see this crosstab and I was just stunned
I did not think never did I expect that
ordinary citizens in the midst of this
crisis we draw a bright line distinction
between Muslims and Islamic
fundamentalist 70 150 180 160 170 444
5118
every theory of prejudice of which i'm
aware should have should lead one to
expect that the anger and the fear that
people felt about islamic
fundamentalists and they surely were
angry and they were frightened should
spill over onto their feelings about
Muslim immigrants who are not very
well-liked in any case but no it turned
out there is this bright line
distinction so what is the distinction
actually mean and here's where I think
my colleagues were just so clever I said
one end of the sample was asked about
Muslims one ends about Islamic
fundamentalists and that's because
another mped and Elise elected was asked
about Christian fundamentalist there are
the Danish version of born-again
Christians very unhappy for example with
gays controversial but indisputably
legitimate here's a comparison of the
level of support for the right of
Muslims to take part in public debate
and that's the level of support for the
right of born-again Christians to take
part in public debate just as much
support for the rights of Muslims as for
the rights of an indisputably Danish
indisputably legitimate group
second item exactly the same result just
as much support third item same result
exactly just as much support fourth item
exactly as much support these results
are being reported in the book that that
we have this coming out paradoxes of
liberal democracy I I think I've been
about is emphatic as I can be and
telling you that I didn't expect to see
what I saw and it took oh boy the better
part of a year to try and hit upon some
hypothesis that would make sense of
results that I just blew me away and and
the hypothesis is this there has to be a
tendency to economy there are a lot of
different groups out there people can't
form judgments about each and every
group one by one by one by one by one
they've got to find some way to simplify
the task how is it task simplified it's
really by thinking of groups of being
one of two types signing them to one or
two categories there are groups like
born again Christians who whose views
are out of step with the mainstream but
they accept the rules of the game call
them out of the mainstream but then
there are groups that whose views are
really at odds with the institutions and
norms of the society and who are not
merely critics their adversaries
so the expectation then was that yes
Muslims like Christian fundamentalist
their views are out of step but they are
not challenging the rules of a Venge
society and like is like like on the
other hand Islamic fundamentalist
against the background of what's
happened what happened here what's
happened there and the crisis itself
they are not merely out of step they're
at odds with and will be treated like
other groups that are also classified as
transgressive so here's an example again
it's one end of the sample we're asked
about neo-nazis and you can see that
Islamic fundamentalists are put in
exactly the same bin as neo-nazis and as
it happens other similarly transitive
trend transgressive groups I want to
close and I want to close by by saying
just a word about what's common to these
three castle lectures and first
is tempted to observe that there are
some paradoxical costs of commitment to
democratic values in the first lecture
what what I showed was that the very
concern with the injustice of racism has
led to a exclusive concentration on ill
will towards black Americans which is
surely commendable but it's come at the
cost of exaggerating the power of
prejudice and overlooking as it happens
altogether the influence of goodwill
among white Americans
I do think that when it comes to
democratic politics everything comes at
a price and and that and that and that
was at the root of the lecture about
multiculturalism as implemented
multiculturalism has been divisive and
and yet as as I think the evidence shows
exactly the ground under which it's been
most divisive that it is that it
undermines the cultural identity of the
national majority has completely
obscured the fact that what is driving
resentment of multiculturalism has
nothing whatever to do with culture and
what's more that that because it has
proven as implemented to be so divisive
it has blinded us to the possibility for
which I gave evidence that there are
conditions a number of conditions under
which multiculturalism can be widely
acceptable
and today what I've tried to show you is
that even some of the studies which show
or seem to show the worst form of
rationality in mass public's namely
preference reversals on closer
examination actually show that choices
are being made choices you may not care
for but they're being made by people
taking the alternatives on offer that
are most consonant with their general
view of the matter and what do I take
all those results to amount to it's that
it requires faith to believe in the
capacity of citizens to contribute to
liberal democracies but there are
crucially reasons for faith and and that
all in all as I said I meant to
illustrate at the beginning citizens are
better at reasoning about political
choices and have better reasons for the
choices that they make then has been
recognized questioned
so I'm just wondering what
we are citizens what does that mean for
creating part of the problems that we
select into France right so real world
politics is not an experiment we have
the frame that we like and we seek over
and over the one that we already have
does that mean that may be creating
forcibly removing us shaking us out of
those brand giving us other side note so
I'm trying to think about you know sort
of what what's the noun that goes before
the participle [ __ ] you know shaking
who's shaking shaking us okay so you
know 115 second summary of research on
local reasoning in mass public's Philip
Congress does rights a remarkable essay
which dominates the thinking of
political scientists from 1964 and it's
still kind of into intuition of the
thoughtful about what citizens are like
and and it's and it's a it's just it's a
it's a story about citizens simply being
disengaged from politics and lacking in
political ideas and then of course you
know that people who think that's a bad
so state of affairs right that we really
should have a world in which citizens
have value commitments
that they should have coherent outlooks
on politics I others become persuaded
that that actually there is a
substantial fraction of the electorate
that has exactly that they they do have
commitments to values they do have
coherent outlooks on political life now
as it happens a democratic politics is
conflict there are opposing points of
view there are opposing values it is
inescapable you know it's it's um it's
sometimes it's just hard to recognize
that there's a point of view other than
yours that is as deeply and
authentically rooted as yours in
politics and so to simplify right versus
left so so what happens in a world in
which people are citizens are capable of
making commitments to a conservative
idea of politics and others are capable
of committed of committing themselves to
a liberal idea of politics then then you
get into a world in which people have
reasons for choice and the more
consistent they are the more coherent
they are and choosing from the
alternatives on offer to fit their
values
the greater the potential that you have
for grounded conflict in the electorate
it also as it happens in some ways makes
them less susceptible to manipulation
they when I when I started I had this
idea of survey experiments I done that
was a good idea I looked into that one
but but the but but I started off with
this idea I still lived in the world
that I you know I you live in the world
you were a graduate student right so I
was a graduate student when when
Congress did his after shortly after is
his exceptional work and I thought then
I had the means to demonstrate that I
could get people to do anything I want
him to do to take any political position
that I want him to take I just would set
up these experiments on authority and
conformity and i remember in one study
on the Canadian Charter of Rights it
almost became parody and it was a
question about you know sort of whether
this person was entitled to a ride or
not entitled to a ride and in the
treatment can in a control condition you
just ask the question in the treatment
condition you're told that the attorneys
general of all of Canada's provinces and
the heads of all of the police
departments in every town of any size
plus all the people who have given any
careful thought to this issue at all
thought that this was the right thing to
do now how about you and and it turned
out that in terms of you know an effect
coefficient it was like point point 09
you know if I think about all of the
experiments that I've done and I once
did this and averaged across all of the
experiments what the effect size is
where of the negative of the
manipulations it's not bigger than point
15 now I can
you can create contrast that are so
great that sure you can it looks as
though you're moving people around but
actually when people when you're sitting
and with them or when you're speaking to
them over the phone or astonishingly
when you're interviewing them online and
you ask them what they think they take
that to be the question what do what do
I think and and and they and they tell
you what they think I was think we just
told him about all those attorneys
general and you know the chief of police
so that that was my that was my
awakening running into the wall learning
that I didn't have the power to push
people around what what would lead to
two experiments that threw light on
political questions was if I gave people
reasons if I gave them arguments if I
gave them considerations that in light
of their values should weigh with them
that can make a difference and and and
that and that is in the end what is
going to be the theme of the book that
comes from these lectures yes I normally
don't speak of these but I input that
might be interesting during Bill
Clinton's presidency there was a bullpen
shown that did his polling and my
impression has it they had about a
hundred pollsters in Denver that were
pulling every night and his hole in his
what big you know good the public's
point of view on
subject but then they would be using
different reasons going through a long
list of different possibilities and and
so that in the morning I think it was
shown couldn't tell the president okay
we'll frame this with this particular
reason and perhaps they knew the
innocent they wanted to get to the
answer they wanted and so they had a
hundred people constantly polling trying
to frame reasons kind of so that he was
effective on prep everyone access
television and sort of your point that
they were seeking the reasons good yeah
create a particular reaction on the part
of the American public Who am I to argue
with the president united states it was
pretty good at doing doing that election
business well I'm ok out with
disagreeing there there there is a
paradox it is that in an electorate
those who are most attentive two reasons
those who can grasp the point of what
was just said to them most acutely are
the very people who have already worked
out their beliefs with the highest
degree of thoroughness and so those who
can can live the language of reasons are
also the people who are very hard to
shift for the and it's and it's and it's
tied up with the fact that they
understand the reason they get it
they've put things together there's
classic problem in political science and
and it takes the form of what
constitutes a rational choice and and in
one tradition the idea of a rational
choice is that you can imagine two
candidates they're located on a
continuum they and and and the rational
choice is to take is to choose the
candidate whose position as closest to
yours and that's been a puzzle several
ways over the the principal reason it's
been attractive the median voter theorem
turns out not to hold except under
really quite restrictive conditions but
the puzzle for people like me is I'm not
going to claim that that that citizens
pay an exceptional amount of attention
to politics they don't even those who
pay a comparatively good deal of
attention to it so how is it that they
can walk around knowing where the
positions of all these candidates are
and so in the studies that we did on
spatial reasoning we said well look hang
on yes there are the two pieces of
information in the classical model which
is the policy positions of do candidates
but there are two other pieces of
information and that's the party's
banner who's the candidates running
under and for those people who have a
view an overall view of politics who are
identify themselves with the party that
matches their overall outlook who
understand that that Republicans are
more conservative than Democrats these
aren't really demanding criterion a lot
of partisans
satisfy them they can deduce correctly
if they know the party labels which
candidate to vote for that will best
satisfy their preferences all in all
okay so I said everything has a price so
so what's the price of being in that
sense capable of a rational choice as we
try to demonstrate what it allows is the
candidate of your party can take any
position that the candidate wants so
long as he or she lines up visa V the
opponent in the right order the Democrat
to the left of the Republican and so
there's this terrible irony that the
Justin so far as as large numbers of
American politics understand what
American politics is about which is
ideological politics they become
prisoners of their own party because
even if their candidate is not the
candidate as closest to them their best
choice is always to support their party
to maximize their preferences all in all
yes
that seemed content but it appeals to
this idea of authority I was just
wondering if you come across cases where
I mean the the short answer is this is
the only time that we did it I mean to
do it the next study that I do one of
the really great advantages of it which
I didn't say is that okay if I take a
liberal position and the interviewer is
trying to talk me out of it they're
going to give me a reason that a liberal
should consider for changing their
position if I take a conservative
position the interview is going to give
me a reason that a conservative should
consider for changing their position so
what if you notice that there's an
asymmetry that liberals you can talk
liberals out of their position more
easily you can talk conservatives out of
well what's the explanation for that
well maybe liberals are more yielding
but then again maybe the argument that
you thought up was stronger but how do
you tell whether it's stronger you tell
whether it's stronger by its effects so
it becomes just thought illogical so the
way we got to the content free counter
argument in truth was we're trying I was
trying to find an argument that could be
given exactly the same two opposing
sides to see which was more susceptible
to change and and the absolutely candid
explanation of how I got the idea was
when I joined a study of politics in
Italy and I saw my collaborators
and and not all stereotypes are totally
false it was just a lot of gesticulation
that was going on and and that's where I
got the idea that we could do something
like the same thing with respondents and
sort of wave our arms around verbally
make like we were saying something and
and I would love to do that over here
when it comes to issues of race love to
actually don't think we should I don't
think we showed on two grounds one in
every area that I can think of except at
the almost the instant of birth effect
and belief run right through each other
but if that's not true in general it is
the heart of the matter when it comes to
politics when we talk about what we care
about the ideas we care about it is we
they're just shot through with our
feelings that's why politics has has
such as a capacity to engage people it's
also why it's the only domain and social
life that I know of where it's not only
acceptable but it's appropriate to heap
disdain on your opponent on those who
disagree with you it's right to say that
they're wrong that they're deeply wrong
they're wrong all the way down and
is the passions but but the idea that
you know that passion is something to do
with the rationality and belief over
here has got something to do with
rationality I think mrs. what drives
politic yeah and the voters that are
politically unaware or they're not
disseminating content free articles but
there they can be persuaded or convinced
of positions as a result of political
elites disseminating justifications that
are not adhering voters could be
provided with bad reasons for why
addition support parties candidates or
policies in a way that they're not
content free is just that they're bad
forms of argumentation that voters don't
recognize bad forms of argumentation or
the incorrect logic that's being used
simply due to their their ignorance I'm
going to say yes and then i'm going to
ask for to beg indulgence and to say
what I said at the very start of the
first lecture
when I got my first job I got invited to
join a research project that research
project was funded and its memories dead
right on this almost a million dollars
nineteen seventy dollars it was to do a
study of social indicators and in my
case specifically political ad nation I
joined that project but but I joined it
out of ambition I didn't have an
interest in the problem I just thought
it was like big machine physics and this
was the way that I was going to get my
career off to a fast start well it was a
bad idea and and as the project went on
in its second and third year I got more
and more agitated and I'd wake up at two
thirty and 3 30 and go downstairs the
library now I take a book and I'd read a
little bit not because I had in trust in
what I was reading I just wanted to read
so that I'd get tired enough to go back
sleep and then one night I woke up again
and went downstairs and my hand fender
fell on the Federalist Papers I didn't
choose him ok I did so I took it out sat
down on herself open them up you know at
random and started to read I read to and
I stopped and and and then said was
suppose you been reading them there and
then how would you have decided would it
have persuaded you
and I knew right in the incident what my
answer would have been I would have said
it's a noble idea doesn't have a prayer
people just aren't up to it and so I
knew in that moment that I was capable
of a world-historical mistake I would
have bet against the best political idea
that's ever been and ever since then the
question that that has occupied me is
what is it that I didn't understand
about about being a citizen that would
have led me to make show horrible a
mistake so yeah I'm with you the you
know the opportunities for people
getting things wrong I you know I don't
know how to quiet I don't what the quant
are but on the other hand i'd insist
that i still don't understand altogether
what I got wrong but i but i but i
believe i've got some better reasons for
understanding why all in all the world
being as it is imperfect as it is if you
get lucky and have some institutions in
place yeah I'll bet on
on on citizens